welcome everyone to this
topic in which we are going to talk
about that what exactly is the different
maven interview questions here
now in this one we are going to talk
about what are the different questions
some couple of questions we are going to
go through
and we will try to understand that what
exactly the answers are
now uh let's talk about the first
question over here so what exactly is in
maven here
so maven is nothing but a kind of a
popular open tool uh open source build
tool which is
available there now before uh maven
there were a couple of
build tools which was present like and
and you know a lot of other
legacy tools was present there but after
that
maven is something which was uh released
as an open source tool
and it really helps the organization to
uh automate some couple of build
processes and
you know have some particular mechanisms
like build publish and
of of different different projects at
once itself
so it's a very powerful tool which can
really help us to do the build
automations we can integrate them with
the other tools like jenkins and
you know we can automate them we can
schedule the builds
so a lot of various advantages we can
get with the help of this
tool here it's primarily written in java
and uh it can be used to build up
various other kind of projects also like
c
sharp scalar ruby etc so all these other
typical tools can also be built up with
the help of this tool
so this tool is primarily uh used to do
the
uh particular development and management
of the artifacts in the java based
projects
so uh for most of the java projects
nowadays this is the default tool
and it's already integrated with the
eclipse also so when you go for a newer
project
automatically it will be created for a
java project you can use it for other
languages also but
yes default choice of java of of the
java programming language is maven build
tool only
now let's talk about next question so
what does the maven help with
so may when apache maven helps to manage
all the processes
such as build process documentation
release process
distribution deployment preparing the
artifact so
all these tasks is being primarily taken
care by the
apache maven so this tool simplifies the
process of project building
it also increases the performance of the
project and the overall building process
so all these things are something which
is being taken care
by the specific maven tool here so it
also
uses the particular uh you know it
downloads the jar files of the different
dependencies
for example if your source code is
dependent on
some of the apache web service jar files
or
some of the other third-party jar files
in that case you don't have to
download those jar files and keep in
some repository or keep it in some lib
directory
you just have to mention that dependency
in the maven and that jar file will be
downloaded
during the build process and will be
cached locally so that's a biggest
advantage which we get with maven that
you don't have to take care of all these
dependencies
anywhere into your source code system so
meven provides easy access to all the
required information
it uh helps the developer to build the
projects and
uh without you know even worrying about
the dependencies processes or different
environments or different
because it's in a kind of a tool which
can be used in any platform linux or
windows so they don't have to do any
kind of conversions
so all they have to do is that they have
to just add new dependencies
and that should be updated into the pom
file and depending on that
dependencies the source code will be
built up and they don't have to refer
any kind of third party jar files so
they don't have to play with the class
bars during the build process so no
customizations
is actually required with this one now
the next question is that
what are the different elements that may
one take cares of
so there are different kind of elements
which is being taken care by maven so
uh these particular parameters are
elements are
bills dependencies reports
distribution releases and mailing list
so these are the typical different
different uh elements which is being
taken care by the maven during the build
process and during the preparation of
the builds here
so all these things you can they can
explore they can extract on that part
and they can fully understand that how
they can
work on all these different different
processes now next question is that what
is the difference
primary difference between the and and
maven first of all both of them are
primarily used for the javascript so and
is the older version and maven is
something which was launched after the
ad here
so and has no formal conventions like so
which can be uh you know coded into the
build.xml file there but yes
the maven has convention so information
is not required as such in the palm.xml
file there
so ant is procedural whereas maven is
declarative over here
so and does not have any kind of life
cycle so it depends on you that how you
program the
and there but maven is having a lot of
life cycles there which we can configure
we can utilize
so the uh and related scripts are not
reusable because you cannot reuse it
and you have to do some kind of
customizations in order to work on that
but yes maven is
not having much of the project related
any kind of dependencies
they can be easily reusable there
because there is nothing about
the palm.xml file it's just the artifact
name and the dependencies which is uh
something we can uh override or we can
change and then the same palm.xml file
we can reuse
as such for the new project also so that
is where the reusability comes into the
picture
now and is a very specific build tool so
we don't have to there is no plugins
as such which is available there you
just have to code everything that what
build process you want to prepare
whereas in case of maven we have the
concept of plugins which can really help
us to understand that how we can
make or use of these plugins so that we
can have the reusability
implemented so these are some of the
differences which is available there
between the ant
and maven here now next thing is that
what exactly isn't palm file all about
so palm file is nothing but it's kind of
a
xml file which is available there and
it's have having all the information
regarding the project and the
configuration details
so it primarily used over here that how
the configuration needs to be done
and how the setup should be performed as
such here
so palm techno file is the build script
which we prepare
you can prepare it using a particular
component
or you can have a particular mechanism
or if you feel that you want to have
some kind of setup so all these things
typically can be implemented can be
done with the help of build tools so
build tools can be really helpful for us
to do the automations and it can really
help us to understand that how
some build processes we can automate
with simply with the help of palm.xml
file here
so the developers usually put up
everything inside these uh dependencies
in the pom.xml file here
so this is the file which is uh usually
present in the home directory it's in
the current directory
so that once the build is triggered it
will be picked up from that directory
and according to the steps according to
the content of the pom.xml file
the build will be processed or will be
created here
now what i'll include into the palm file
here so
the different components which is
included into the palm dot xml file here
is the dependencies
uh developers and contributors plugins
plugin configuration and resources so
these are the typical components which
is a part of a
xml file which can be uh same form a lot
of projects you can do some
customization and then
the same pump file can be reused for the
other projects
also now one of the minimum requirement
of
the elements which is there for a pump
for uh pom.xml file
so without which the pound.xml file will
not be validated and
will will be getting a kind of
validation errors so the minimum
required elements are project root
model version so it should be 4.0.0 the
group id of the project the artifact id
of the project
and the version of the artifact these
are the minimum things which we want to
define so that we can understand that
what kind of artifact we are trying to
prepare or we are trying to create here
so these are the minimum required
elements which is required in the
pom.xml file without which the
validation of the pom file will fail
and the build will also fail here
now what exactly is the mint uh with the
term called build tool
so build tool is an essential tool is a
kind of a process for building or
compiling the
source code here so it's needed or it's
required for the below
for generated processes if you want to
generate the source code if you want to
compile the source code you want to
generate the source code
you want to generate some documentation
from the source code
you want to compile the source code or
you want to package the source code
whether it's a jar file it's a war file
or it's a er file
so whatever the packaging mode you want
to select you will be able to do it with
the help of
the particular build tool here and if
you feel that you want to
upload these particular artifacts to the
artifactory
whether it's on remote machine or
locally there so that also you can do it
with the help of
this particular build tools here so
build tools can be
helpful in doing a lot of activities for
the developers
now one of the different steps which is
involved to install maven on windows
now all you have to do is that you have
to just first of all download the
tar file from the maven apache maven
repository there
once that is done so what happens that
you have to set up some couple of
environment variables
now if you download the java jdk using
the exe file in that case the java
underscore
home will be configured automatically
but if it is not available and you are
not able to run the java command line
in that case you have to set up the java
underscore home
and then similarly for maven you have to
go for the maven underscore home
that particular variable you have to
configure now once that is done
all you have to do is that you have to
edit the path variable
so the bin directory of the maven
extracted a folder you have to put it up
into the path variable
and once that is done what will happen
that you will be able to
check the latest version the version of
the maven over there if it is like some
old version
again you have to extract the latest
version and do the steps all together
again
so these are some of the ways that in
which you can actually go for the
installation or the
configurations of maven on the windows
platform
now what are the different steps which
is involved for the installation of
maven and ubuntu
so ubuntu it's fine you just download
the package of java jdk there
once the jdk is installed over there
what you can do you can simply go ahead
and say that yes
i want to search for a particular maven
package which is available there
so once the jdk is installed all you
have to do is that you have to configure
the java underscore home
m3 underscore home maven and disco home
and the path variable
once all the path variables are
something which is configured
then you will be able to check the
latest version like whether it's
the version is correct or we are getting
the standard version
over here or not over here so that's the
main mechanism that how
we will be able to you know configure
the maven on ubuntu here now what
exactly is the command to install to
char
into the locals repository now sometimes
what happens that
we are not able to fetch like uh some
dependencies not present on the
uh particular central repository minimum
repository or your artifactory
repository
in that case you have some third-party
jar which we want to install locally
onto your repository so in that case we
can go for the
uh but we can download the jar file
there and then we can run the command
called mvn
install install hyphen file and then we
are giving the path like hyphen d file
where the path of the file should be
provided now once that is done so what
will happen that in the local
dot m2 directory this specific artifact
will be downloaded and will be installed
there
so this is a mechanism where you will be
able to configure or you will be able to
set up
the artifacts locally the java file
locally here in the local repository
so next question is that how do you know
that the version of the maven being used
here
so the inversion of the maven is pretty
easy to calculate
so all you have to do is that you have
to just go for mvn
and space hyphen iphone version the
moment you do that it will let you know
that what jdk or what java version you
are using
and it will also show you that what
particular maven version
you're going to use here so all that
details you will be able to get with
that particular command here
now what exactly is the clean default
and frightened variable here so these
are the build cycles which is available
there in within maven
so these are the built-in build cycles
so for clean what
happens that this life cycle will help
you to perform the project cleaning
so usually during the build there are
some files which is created into the
target directory
so the clean life cycle is essentially
helping us to clean up all that
directory
all that particular target directory and
when we talk about the
specific default so default lifecycle
handles the projector deployment
that is the default lifecycle and site
is something which is uh you know
helpful for creating the site
documentation
you know it's kind of a life cycle which
is available there so clean
default and site are the different life
cycles which can perform different
different
kind of uh attributes or different tasks
here next question
what exactly is an even repository so
maven repository
refers to the directories of the package
jar
files that contain metadata now the
metadata refers to the palm
files relevant to each project so here
you can able to get your artifacts
uh stored there you can download these
artifacts also during the maven build
if you put up that dependency you will
there are different kind of repositories
which is available there one is the
local repository
one is a remote repository and one is
the central repository
so these are the different typical type
of repositories which we have
where we can store the artifacts also
and from where we can download the
artifacts also whenever required
now the first one is the local
repository so local repository refers to
the machine of the developers itself
where all the project related files are
stored there now whenever we work on the
uh particular maven so there is an in
the home directory dot
m2 folder is created now usually
whatever the artifacts downloaded from
artifactory or from the maven repository
it gets cached locally there and once it
is downloaded next time it will not
download the same artifacts or the same
dependency all together again so this
local
repository is something which is
available locally on the
developers machine only so it contains
all the dependent jars
which a particular developer is
downloading during the maven build
now remote repositories refers to the
repository which is present on the
server
and uh from where we will be downloading
the uh particular dependencies
so the when when we are running the
maven build on a fresh machine
so usually over there the local
repository does not exist
so in that case what happens that the
dot m2 directory is empty
but the moment you run the build what
will happen that the artifacts or the
dependencies
will be downloaded from the remote
repository and uh once it is done
once it's uh downloaded it will be added
or it will be downloaded
cached locally there and it will be
helpful in the future run so that will
be
considered as a local repository because
all the artifacts
all the dependencies are downloaded
there and central repository is
something which is known as the maven
community
where all the artifacts is available
there so usually we cache
or we mirror these central repositories
as our particular
remote repositories because it could be
a possibility that these remote
repositories are something
which we are hosting into our
organization and central repository is
something which is available centrally
for everyone
to use it so these are something
you know some kind of repositories where
each and every artifacts will be stored
and anyone will be able to have the
access to these uh particular
artifacts here so these artifacts are
every artifacts every open source uh
artifacts is something which is
available
over there to these central repository
now how does the
maven architecture really work here so
the main architectural really works in
the three steps
the very first step is that it reads the
palm.xml file here that's the very first
step
second it downloads the dependencies
defined in the panel.xml file into the
local repository
from the central or the remote
repository here once that is done so it
will
uh you know create or generate the
reports according to the
life cycles which you have configured
whether it's a clean
install site deploy
package or whatever the life cycle you
want to trigger you will be triggering
that particular life cycle
and corresponding to that the build or a
specific task will be performed
so these are the three steps in which
the overall build
or any kind of uh execution of palmer
xml file
really happens here now what exactly is
the maven build lifecycle
so maven lifecycle isn't nothing but
collection of steps here
that needs to be uh followed for doing a
proper
build of a project here so there are
primary three built-in
cycles which is available there default
which handles the project deployment
clean which handles the project uh
cleaning there and site which handles
the creation of the project sites
documentation
so these are the three primary built-in
build cycles
life cycles which is available as such
now so build lifecycle has you know
different kind of phases or the stages
here
because in the previous uh particular
slide we were talking about what
what are the different uh particular
build life cycles which is available
there
but these are the different phases like
what are the different step-by-step
executions like for the deep down which
is available there
inside a specific maven build lifecycle
so here you can see that
it's compiling then the test compile
test execution is there then package
integration test to verify install and
the lastly deploy here so these are the
different
build phases which is available as such
over here
so what exactly is the command to use to
do a particular maven site
so mvn site is something which is used
to create a maven site here
now usually whatever the artifacts is
prepared that will be prepared in the
target directory
so here also you will be able to see a
site directory which is available there
in the target directory
which you can refer for the site
documentations what is the different
conventions used while
naming a project in may 1. so usually
it involves three components so the full
name of a project in maven includes
first of all the group id
uh for example count.apache com.example
so these are some of the
particular way that where you can
provide the group id artifact id can be
exact project name like maven project
or whatever the project you are creating
so sample project example project
so these kind of things will be there in
the artifact id
and lastly is the version like which
version of your artifact you want to
prepare like 1.0.0
hyphen snapshot 2.0.0 so like this
information you are providing that what
particular version you are trying to
configure here
now let's move on to the intermediate
level where we will be having a little
bit more complex questions
related to the maven here now what
exactly is a maven artifate
now usually what happens that when we do
a build process
as an end of result of the build process
we will get some artifacts
for example when we build a.net project
so there we will be able to have a exe
or dll files
as an artifacts similarly in case of
maven when we do a build process
there we get the different kind of
artifacts like depending on the
packaging mode like
jar file var files or the er files here
so these are something which is you know
getting generated during the build
process during the main process
and you can store them into your local
repository or you want to push them to
the
remote repository it's something that
totally depends on you
so maven is a tool which can help you to
create all the artifacts whether it's a
jar file whether it's a var files or
whether it's a
er file here and every artifact is
having three attributes the first one is
the group
id the artifact id and a particular
version and that's how you will be able
to identify a full-fledged artifact
as such in maven so maven is not about
only the name of the jar file
it's actually referring to the
attributes like crop id the artifact id
and the version of the artifact here now
what are the different phases of the
clean life cycle here
so clean is something which is being
used to clean the target directory so
that a fresh build can be triggered
there
so there are three steps pretty clean
clean and post clean here
so if you wish that you want to override
the particular life cycle configurations
and you want to run some particular
steps before the clean activity
so you can do it into the pre-clean and
if you want to do it like some steps
after clean
then post clean can be utilized now what
are the different
phases of the site life cycle so
pre-site
site post site and site deploy so these
are the different phases which is
available there in the
site life cycle what is exactly we meant
by the maven plugin
now this is the huge difference between
the ant and even here because
in and we were not having this that much
support of the plugins and that's the
reason why we had to deal with all the
build configurations
so we have to simply put the overall
build process
that how the build should be triggered
but that is not something which is there
in case of maven
in maven we have a lot of flexibility
because we can actually put up
what exactly build configurations we
want to put here we can
put some features like important
features over here in maven
and uh these plugins we can utilize for
example i want to perform a compilation
now i don't really want to do any kind
of configurations in this one so
what i can do is that i can simply use
the compilation plugin in maven
and that can really help me because i
don't have to unnecessarily write or
rewrite the configuration that how the
compilation should be done
it's something which is pre-configured
or pre-written in these plugins
that i can simply import the plugin and
i can do the build process or the
compilation process
in a pretty standard mode so i don't
really have to
do any kind of workarounds with that and
simply with the small
automations i will be able to reach that
how this maven plugins can be integrated
into my palm or xml file
and i can desire or i can have some
particular procedures
and some steps executed there so that's
the biggest benefit
which we really get with the help of
maven plugins now
why exactly the maven plugins are
utilized so to create a jar files
to create the war files to compile the
code files
to perform the unit testing to create
the project documentation and to create
the project reports
so there are variety of things in which
we can actually use these maven plugins
through the integrations within the
palm.xml file there so it's all about
the plugins
you just import the plugin and that
desired activity will be performed there
now what are the different type of
plugins which is there so
you can have either build projects
for performing the build activities you
can have some build plugins
for reporting plugins also there which
can be only generated or utilized
to generate the reports to process the
reports and do
any kind of formatting or any kind of
processing on the reports here so that
is where the reporting plugins
are utilized now what is exactly the
difference between the convention
and the configuration in maven so
convention is in particular process when
the developers
are not required to create the build
processes so configuration is when
you know the developers are supposed to
create the build processes
so the users do not have to rectify the
configuration in detail
and once the project is created it will
automatically create
a structure so they must specify
every in case of configuration you have
to provide each and every details
so that's how the configurations really
happens because
you have to put every detail into the
power xml file
and that's how the particular
configurations really work as such
so this is the huge difference between
the conventions and the configurations
here
now so why exactly said that maven uses
conventions
over the configuration maven pretty much
does not puts any efforts like on the
particular developers that they have to
put each and every configuration so
there are some ready-made
plugins which is available there and
pretty much we are making use of that so
that in such a case we don't have to
worry about
the executions and we will be able to
pretty much work on that
so conventions like maven uses the
conventions incident of the
configurations
so the developers just no they don't
just have to create the maven project
the rest of the particular structure
will be taken here automatically
so they are not uh you know expecting
that the developers should be doing the
configuration work
and everything should be taken care in
such a way that you just have to start
the things
and rest of the things should be taken
care by the maven itself so maven will
be
uh responsible because they do the
plugins
it will be responsible to set up the
default architecture
the default folder structures and all
you have to do is that you have to just
place the source code in the desired
folder structure here so that's
something which you need to do
as on particular developers so what
exactly is the maven
order of inheritance here so the order
of inheritance is the settings
cli parameters parent palm and the
project palm which means that
if you have some configuration and
settings that will be the highest value
then the cli parameters are there then
the parent palm is there
and then the project pump so this is the
way that how the
particular parameters or the
configurations will be picked up by the
may one so
that's the order so what does the build
life cycles and the phases
imply in the basic concept of maven so
build life cycles
consist of a sequence of build phases
and each build
phase consists of a sequence of goals
when a phase is run
uh all the goals related to that phase
and its plugins are
also compiled so you will be able to
have a lot of
particular goals which is residing
inside of phase there
and similarly life cycle is nothing but
a kind of a sequence of the different
phase
so life cycle comes in the top then it
comes on the phases and then it comes on
the goals here
now what is the terminology called goal
in case of maven
the term a terminology goal refers to
the specific task
that makes it possible for the the
project to be built and
organized so it's something which we can
run so it's an
actual implementation which is going on
there for example in the build process
in the
build phase i have a different goals
like clean
install package deploy these are the
different typical
goals which is available there which i
can execute
into the main one here so these are the
different goals like uh which we can
execute and which we can run during a
maven build
next question is what is exactly meant
by the term dependencies and the
repositories in maven here
so dependencies refer to the java
libraries which we
usually put up into the pound.xml file
there now what happens that sometimes
our source code is requiring some java
files like a
secondary java files for performing the
build process so
instead of downloading it and storing it
into the class path for during the build
process
we just have to specify the dependency
of that
artifact what dependency we need to put
and once that dependency is put up there
we will be able to have that jar file
downloaded
and cached into the local repository
during the maven build project
now if the dependencies are not present
in your local repository
then maven will try to download it from
the central repository and again if it
is not uh
uh you know it's something which is
available which is downloaded from the
central repository then it will be
cached locally into the
local repository so that's the cycle
which is being implemented and
utilized during this process now what
exactly is in snapshot in maven
so snapshot refers to the version
already available in the movement report
repository
it signifies the latest development copy
that's what we
do with the case of snapshot here so me
even checks for a new version of
snapshot in the remote repository for
every new build
so during the build process like you
know a new snapshot version is being
downloaded
and the snapshot is updated by the data
service team which
uh with updated source code every time
to the repository for each maven build
so snap shot is something which we will
be using like very frequently we will be
updating to that
and frequently we will be updating the
version to that and we will try to
explore and we'll try to do the
modifications
now what are the different type of
projects available in maven so there are
thousands of java projects which
you know uh can be utilized or we can be
uh implemented by
my one here so this helps the as the
user
that they as they no longer have to
remember every configurations
to set a particular project for example
spring boot
spring mvc spring boot etc these are the
different projects which is
already available in maven so most of
the we have already discussed that
uh for the job-based projects maven is
something which is you know considered
as by default
so a lot of organizations are actually
using it for you know storing
or utilizing it for the particular
maven project now what exactly is the
maven uh
archetype over here so maven octave
refers to a maven plugin that is uh
entitled to create a for project
structure as per its template
these archetypes are just project
templates that are generated by maven
when any new project is created there so
this is something which we are using
so that we will be able to create a
fresh new projects
right so let's go on to the advanced
level of this maven questions
now what exactly is the command to
create a new project
based on an archive type so mvn
archetype
generate is used to create a new java uh
project based on the archetype
now this will take up some parameters
from
as an end user from you and depending on
that parameters
it will create the palm.xml file it will
create the source directories
uh inside that main java test all these
different couple of directories
directory structures will be
automatically created now why we require
this command
so that if you are going to create a
project from scratch from the
uh from the day one this command will
help you to have all the folder
structures created
and then further on you can put up your
source code and those files
as such in this folder structure so
that's how
is the mechanism that we will be able to
see that how the setup can be performed
really over here now what does maven
clean implies now movement clean is a
plugin that
suggests that it's going to clean the
files and directories there so whenever
we do a build process usually in the
target directory we have some class
files
some jar files or whatever the generated
source code which is available
that will be present in the darker
directory so the maven
clean is something which is available
which is going to clean all these
directories
and why we are doing this directly
structure cleanup
so that we will be able to do a fresh uh
build process
and there should not be any kind of
issues
as such over here so that's the main
reason why we are looking forward for
this
uh particular mechanism or for this uh
particular changes
as such here now so what exactly isn't
build profile all about so build
profiles refers to the set of
configurations
uh where we can have like typically two
different kind of build processes there
so if you feel that the same form.xml
file you can use you want to run for
different different
particular configurations so that you
will be able to do pretty much
with the help of this component so build
profile is used to do a customization
processes so that you will be able to
have the process
and you will be able to perform the
configurations and the setups
all together there so that's a very
important aspect to be considered that
which we need to
uh discuss when we talk about the build
profile so build profile
whenever you feel that you want to do
some customizations and you want to
proceed with the
setup so that's where it's utilized next
thing is that what are the different
type of build profiles which is
available there
so the build profiles can be done on for
a particular project
like per project you can do you can uh
even do the build profiles in the
settings.xml file also
and if you feel that you want to do it
into the globalsettings.xml file so that
also
you can do as such over here so there
are different ways
in which you can do the customization
and once the customization is done
you will be able to have the different
ways of doing the setups
and the configurations over there so
what exactly is meant
by the uh particular system dependencies
here so
let's talk about that also so system
dependencies refers
to the uh particular mechanisms where we
feel that uh how the dependencies
should be uh you know present there so
that is something which is having a
scope of system there
so these dependencies are commonly used
to help maven
know the dependencies that is being
provided by the jdk
system dependencies are mostly used to
resolve
the dependencies on the artifacts that
are provided by the jdk so these
dependencies are somewhat which is being
utilized
and used over here so that we will be
able to implement
and go ahead through the system
dependencies what is the reason for
using
an optional dependency here so optional
dependencies are used to decrease the
transitive burden of some libraries so
what happens that
when you download an artifact when you
put up a dependency so it could be a
possibility that
some dependencies as in particular
optional can also be downloaded
now these are not always required but
yes sometimes what happens that these
are downloaded so that you don't have to
put
uh each and every uh artifact or
dependency into the power xml file for
example
you're trying to download some apache
tool and with that some like three four
jar files or three four another
dependencies are also getting downloaded
now if you are using that dependencies
that
totally create because you don't have to
put that uh list
or that entry in the dependency list in
the partner xml file
and that can really save your time but
if you feel that you don't want to have
them and you
these are the optional ones and you
really want to get rid of that so that
also you can exclude
while downloading any kind of
dependencies so these are the optional
ones
which depending on your requirement you
can utilize you can
process and if you feel that you don't
want to get it you won't want to process
it
you can certainly ignore it and you can
get rid of that also
now what is a dependency scope and how
many type of dependencies
scope are there so there are different
type of dependency scores which is there
which is used on each and every stage of
the build here
so compile provided runtime test
system import these are the different
kind of dependency scopes
which we have using which we can define
that when exactly we want to go ahead
for a specific build process so
depending on your requirement
you can explore all these build scopes
and you can get benefits
out of that what is exactly an
intransitive
dependency in maven so maven avoids the
need to find out and specify libraries
that our own dependencies require by
including the transitive dependencies
automatically
so transitive dependencies says that if
he depends if x depends on y
and y depends on z then x depends on y
and both there
so which means that you are not
depending on one artifact
you also need the z artifact there with
the y
artifact so that is what you need to do
so that you will get both the
dependencies there
because this is normal that if you are
trying to
download some particular artifacts or
download some dependency
and that dependency is also dependent on
some other artifact or
some other jar file then you have to
include both of them
so this is something which you will be
able to get so that
you uh can easily download all these
dependent
jar files also and the maven build can
be success
how can a maven build profile can be
activated so even
build profile can be activated
throughout different ways so
explicitly using the command command
line you can
talk about that which profile you want
to execute through maven settings you
can do
uh based on environment parameters os
settings
and present and missing files so these
are the different ways
in which you can actually activate that
which particular profile you want to
have so profiles configurations
can also be saved in various situations
and various files
and from there you will be able to refer
that which file you want to refer
as such now what is meant by the
dependency exclusion
the exclusion is used to exclude any
transitive dependency because you never
know
that if you are trying to put up a
dependency uh
entry in the palm xml file that artifact
is also further dependent on
another artifact so in order to feel in
order to see that you want to exclude
that
dependent artifact which is being
automatically downloaded
that also we can exclude with the help
of exclusion so you can
avoid the transitive dependency with the
help of
dependency exclusions here so what
exactly is in mojo so mojo is nothing
but maven plain old java
object here so it's an executable goal
in maven
and a plug-in refer to the distribution
of such mosos so moses enable
the maven to extend its functionality
that already is not founded in so it's
kind of an extension which is there and
using this we can get
some additional benefits and some
executions over there
so what is the command to create a new
project based on a hard drive
so again archetype is something which we
normally use to create
the new projects now you can give the
parameters in the command itself
or you want it to in in kind of an
interactive mode
where it will take the parameters from
the end user and according to that the
project will be created
onto hard drive or onto server wherever
you wish you want to create you can
create a new project
so explain about the maven settings.xml
file so maven settings.xml file contains
the elements that are used to define
that how
the maven execution should be there so
there are different uh settings like
local remote central all these different
repositories are configured as such over
here
now in this case what happens that uh
usually the configurations are done in
such a way
that it can you know go for the
executions it can go for the build
process
and the complete executions can be
involved and can be achieved as such
here so all these
executions are something which we can
really perform and uh
here we can put some credentials how to
connect to the remote repository how to
connect to remote repository
all that stuff is something which we
talk about over here what exactly is a
meant by term
superbomb here so super form refers to
the default bomb of maven
so the moms of maven can derive from so
it's nothing but a reference to a parent
bomb
which is available there that is a super
pump so if you define some dependencies
in that super pump
automatically the uh child bomb will
also be able to inherit all those
dependencies
so we can put some uh executions like we
can put some
configuration in the super pump so that
if multiple
projects are going to refer that they
should be able to refer that easily so
that's the reason why we primarily use
the super pump
so that we can have the execution some
processes
put up over there and all the other
projects should be effort to refer or
inherit from there
so where exactly the dependencies are
stored so dependencies are stored
like in different locations like you
have the local repository
remote repository is there local
repositories on the
local developers machine and remote
repository something which is available
on a server in form of
artifactory so that was some of the
questions from the
particular maven depending on the
beginner advance and the
intermediate level over here so that's
what we have for this
thanks
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here